oh
[Music]
hey guys now you know that i love honest
amish beer products right we also did
free giveaways on my instagram page a
few months ago but i never gave you guys
an honest review video
so
today is the day i brought in two guys
you remember them beast and smiley hey
guys hey
[Music]
they've never tried it before so you
guys are going to try it out yeah yeah
yeah sounds good all right let's do it
[Music]
all right there you go what do you think
yeah i like it so far it looks good okay
yeah i really like the packaging um i'm
excited to try it out
all right you guys have four weeks to
try it out all right we're gonna film
you as well and then you're gonna give
your honest treat 3d ready yeah we're
going to see if this really works yeah
ready let's do this
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hey guys so it's been a while we just
wanted to test it out for a couple of
weeks but it's been over two months two
months it's been only long pretty much
two months look at your beards they've
grown yeah we tested it longer
but you shaved it a little bit and then
it
grew longer as well again yeah i know it
is all right so you guys ready for the
review yeah i'm excited to give the
review i think it's pretty good products
yeah beast yeah and also very impressed
um like the product like the textures
and smells everything that goes with it
good products
can i go first yeah yeah sure go ahead
honestly then honestly
okay first up is the packaging the
packaging is really neat and it feels
like you're opening a present the labels
on the products themselves are a little
hard to get used to as they don't have a
clear description of what product is in
which container so uh do you guys agree
yeah yeah yeah i found it also a little
bit difficult just to read if you need
to pick it up real quick just to see
which product is which
especially the start when you're not
used to the progress it is yeah so what
else
so the first thing i noticed was the
smell
and after using it for a couple of weeks
i can say the scent is long lasting and
will keep your beard not just looking
good but also smelling fresh
okay cool and what do you guys think
about the beard soap yeah i think this
was actually my favorite um the fact
that you don't need a lot when washing
your beard and um leaves your beard
smelling natural but that awesome smile
you just talked about um and the best
part of it it doesn't dry out your
wheels absolutely just work definitely
plus yeah all right
what's up next
okay so next up is the beard comb which
is a handy little tool for a curly beard
like mine
it also has a wood texture and it glides
through your beard with ease okay cool
what do you think beast yeah i like the
i like the idea of adding it to the box
it's quite a nice addition to the
gifting box um i just personally prefer
brush which works a little bit easier
with with my beard all right so what do
you guys think about the wax yeah quite
i quite like it understand again the
smell of the of the wax across all of
the products is quite nice
um good to keep your beard in place
especially on that bad bit days uh when
nothing seems to work
i can definitely relate with the bad
beard days
i have a really curly beard so it's
definitely helpful so next up is the
beard oil
so yeah i have to be a bit careful uh
for rubbing your beard on your clothes
because it will leave a stain
especially if you have a long beard yeah
what do you think about the oil
i quite liked um the fact that you don't
need to use too much of it understand
and it
keeps your beard nice and soft and
conditioned on a daily basis something
also good for for daily use yeah it will
definitely last long as well
i just just again uh i think i'm talking
about this too much with the smell of
the panasonic just that natural manly
woody smells and that's
nice
the smell is definitely a bonus yeah
when i first started to use beer
products uh i used too much oil so it
would drop on a lot of stuff and even
when i go to bed i wouldn't take it off
or rinse it out and then it would end up
in my pillow which is which is not what
you want all right guys so what's next i
think the next thing that we need to
talk about is the viet bom oh yeah yeah
we received two of them in the package
from honest damage uh on the original
and in the bio blend personally i prefer
the fire blend so i'm just a little bit
nicer smelling a good texture only thing
that i can recommend is just not using
too much of it because it can become a
little bit weighing that's right
yeah one thing i noticed was the
increase of thickness on my beard which
is also really nice yeah that's cool so
all in all you guys like it yeah yeah
i'll give them a thumbs up
uh from packaging through the products
um textures and then also just the
effect i can really see an improvement
in my viet
softness
so yeah i really like it all right i've
been using it myself for a while and i
do like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the only thing i don't like is the label
like you said smiley when you look at
all the products i mean they're they're
so similar
and you have to look close
just to see what it is it's like is it
wax is it uh beard bomb what is it yeah
it's definitely a little hot uh to read
at first but as you get used to
using containers it isn't really that
big of a problem
but yeah definitely something they can
work on if you guys want to check it out
check out the video description we've
added the links for you and then if
you're new to the channel check out one
of these videos and we'll see you there
and always remember this life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys bye